Hales going bros my name is peter pan
and welcome to a little old thing that
we call Frannie we'd be in pain hey
how's it going it's been a while I'm
sorry I haven't done one of these in a
while uh but you know life life best
excuse ever I mean a lot of stuff has
changed we are in this new set up now it
seems that you bros guy you stirred
fairly quickly I got this beard that
doesn't really want to settle in it's
like we're fighting and my the beard is
not winning no one is winning
honestly you bros want me to shave the
beard so much that I just want to keep
it and I don't even care how ugly it
looks but thank you I really appreciate
the compliments anyway I just wanted to
make this video to make some updates
like I said I've been doing a lot of
live streams lately over at twitch or
here at YouTube basically I livestream
my recording in a sense there's been a
lot of hilarious moments so far so make
sure you follow me too so you don't miss
it
what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
wake up oh my god holy [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
with god damn it ah what
Oh Oh mind blows ah what state how do
how would you know that how would you
know are you sold on this concept yet
good I've been really enjoying doing the
live streams because I feel like I can
connect with you bros being live also by
doing these longer let's play series and
that you bros really seem that you love
and I'm glad you brothers are enjoying
it keep checking them out now there's
one thing that I should have done
forever ago and it's the shout out
competition I announced it a long time
ago now I didn't think we would get so
many submissions my god were there so
many submissions me just looking at the
amount of pages of submissions I wanted
to but we do have the winners and I'm
gonna bring them out net basically try
to look for people that do something
different I know that's hard when you're
starting off and you're new on YouTube
but I really think that's what gave me
that the the edge when I was starting
off was because I I think it's fine if
you want to do what everyone else is
doing but when I started playing horror
games which wasn't popular at all at the
time that's when my my channel actually
took speed so so I want to award people
for being original there were so many
amazing channels and I don't want anyone
to get discouraged because I didn't pick
them first one is Nick a 30 his channel
does Last of Us multiplayer stuff it's
really funny and I haven't seen anyone
else do this so I thought that was
pretty cool
check them out subscribe and that's the
point of me doing this next up we have
yang man which that name doesn't make
any sense she does a mix of live streams
talking about topics playing games and
it's pretty cool and finally we have
welcome to Stone well welcome to soon
toasters we have welcome to Sisto nia
which do sfm animations
they're super talented so funny and
I thought it deserved a shout-out now
I'm adding a list of people that I
thought were really good as well and I
think they deserve a shout-out and I'm
gonna link them in the description so
definitely go check them out I'm really
happy to do these shoutout competitions
because I feel I've been very lucky on
YouTube and I know I know what it's like
to be a smaller Channel and I'm happy to
be helping out people other than me
because I'm just a generous person and
good-hearted and I'm just such a great
person and YouTube has not gone to my
head whatsoever
I gotta say I'm very proud of the latest
videos that has been uploaded working
really hard to make sure they're the
best quality possible and I'm very proud
of it at the same time I know for some
people he might not seem like I do a lot
but at the same time we announce rebel
mode and it's really cool and there's so
much cool stuff that's gonna happen but
it's also very scary because it's my
name on a on a business and they I
wanted to do well so I'm working really
really hard on rebel mode as well so
it's a lot to balance the channel and
these other projects but it's a lot of
fun I'm having a blast and I wouldn't be
able to do any of it if it wasn't for
you bros watching I just want to say I
really appreciate it just thanks for
watching my videos finally I want to
announce a new competition you bros are
going to be able to participate so you
know my intro right how's it going bros
the spirit back I want you bros to do
your best version of my intro but in a
creative way
it could be animated it could be while
skydiving it could be I don't [ __ ]
know just surprise me
alright the more creative the better I
will select the best ones and show them
in a video and I think that it should be
a lot of fun so check out the link in
description for more info on how to
submit that's it for me for now and as
always thank you both so much for
watching I really really really do
appreciate it
and as always I'm kidding alright [ __ ]
stay awesome gross